salut aujourd'hui nous allons analyser
des vidéos et pas n'importe lesquels et
pas avec n'importe qui avec un mix m et
on va analyser des vidéos de magie de
mentalisme qui ont raté d'accord
d'accord jamais page apprend le concept
avec vous
kbc orange je me dis c'est intéressant
de voir ça avec un profane entre
guillemets pour voir si tu vois que le
moment ça va rater pourquoi ça va rater
qu'elle était peut-être le secret du
toit avant qu'on le voit pas ce qu'on le
voit forcément où la plupart du temps et
voir si tu as des solutions à proposer
pour que ça n'arrive plus jamais jamais
jamais jamais donc c'est que des gens
qui ont fait il te donne moi des gens
qui sont en pente halifax chez mega man
talisman magie gtoi plus de magie mais
sûrement thalys le plus gros fail c'est
tu penses à une tomate et le mec te fais
n'a à ma gauche a souvent pas un gros
fail à la vidéo connaît
donc on est en pologne très bien je
parle peu et luis est un mentaliste
polonais peut répudier la carte vidéo
fabien olicard star ac et donc donc oui
il était il n'était pas connu dans ce
tour depuis il est connu mais je pense
pas qu'il se fasse plus en plus rarement
il a reconnu dans la rue mais plus en
mode explique il ya un casque sachs
l'identique
je suis par le polonais ou comment ça
non je venais tour ya 4 à 4,5 en carton
voilà sinon tout est dans vos mains des
sacs et une surprise maintenance alors
en plus ce qui est intéressant tu vas
voir c'est que lui va déjà une vaste
reculé par rapport à 5 mais même s'ils
sont identiques
les sacs sont toujours différents le
maire de wissant kyi win qui en a un qui
est un vieux possède un petit sketch sur
le feu il arrivé est-ce que tu sol
mentalisme monta en toi et est ce que tu
sens le fail au maroc je me l'a dit je
me dis enfin puisque deux présentateurs
ils sont là en mode a enfin on vient de
se parler de la guerre en syrie de
machin géant j'ai un peu de mal à chaud
enfin la détente et moi ça les faisait
en plus visuellement ça va être tout
mélanger non je n'ai quand le mélange
voit bien que lui à mélanger et qui
s'est du coup comment il a mélangé un
grade sans se faire un peu d analyse non
verbale en même temps à temps en temps
est-ce que son tour c'est que lui va
retrouver je ne sais pas max il y en a
tant attendre maintenant il va proposer
aux mecs de chercher
tu vas est ce que tu sens le doute m
ennuie non non mais attends j'ai déjà
alors déjà le concept de gmail ans j'ai
moi même
il faut que je retrouve ou et le pic il
est déjà au fond d'écran incroyable
c'est là que la ville attendait à ce qu
ils disent allez-y et et son mélange
c'était vraiment il avait tout dans les
mains il a fait ça comme ça et puis
s'est retourné monsieur attends je suis
alors là vraiment bas pour laisser le
suspense non mais comme c'est un
magicien se marier recevoir mais le 8 de
pique
ils seront tous ses vues bon ok est-ce
que juste parmi ce qui va s'emparer la
main dis moi que je pense que oui je
pense que c'est tout l'intérêt de ces là
j'ai juste à temps il ya mieux que 200
palais daming ya empalé la main de
quelqu'un qui a rien demandé
j'étais content je viens de voir que la
vie de sa pelle à la main transmis la
peau à 39 par un coup de magie raté il
lui dit tu choisis celui que tu veux
jeter c'est vraiment le but du
mentalisme et de la magie c'est de
générer des belles émotions tu vois à
quel point elle se sent bien
actuellement ça donc le lien à aucun
moment il est sûr de lui et henri maire
et de l'est va dire invasives ou trois
manches alors que juan fois qui sait pas
trop si fait
ce que j'aime quand même c'est qui lui
enlève le pi coresight tu te tais alors
ça en direct à aucun moment les la prod
se débarrasse ne l'évacué mais c'est ça
voilà l'analyse de comment il aurait pu
faire pour réussir en fait y'a aucune
manière de rater si tout allait bien
qu'il ya plein de manières de faire ce
truc là avec plein de deux techniques
différentes mais là il ya le truc de
base
il a mélangé lui-même fait j'aurais fait
du filet alors lui le faire de lui faire
mélangez 1 de manière à une main une
main innocente
ouais ces morts sont pas du tout
innocente on est d'accord donc après
fait genre il cherche alors qu'il vient
de mélanger
jacques faty s'est absolument pas oui le
club med est censé le savoir il aurait
pu en parler mais ils ont peut-être il
savait moi je pense qu'il sait pas une
fac parce que c'était à la télé que ça
lui met la pression était un mode il
faut que j'assure un truc hyper badass
parce que ça peut changer ma vie et tout
ça tu vois pas ce que tu penses que du
coup au moment où elle va taper il se
dit on voit je sais pas mais c'est à la
télé c'est trop tard non signalé quoi je
pense vraiment qu'il avait retardé le
déclin sur devis sur je pense que là il
une fausse pression en mode j'ai plus de
films et bien sa main tu vois mais moi
c'est ça fait fatwa
déjà il tient le truc parce qu'il se dit
mais attend il ya le pic là il je pense
qu'il n'a pas vu tout de suite que c'est
dans sa main
là ils le voient oui la réaction c'est
horrible génial au début ils touchent le
truc de dingue à le petit bout de papier
donc c'est bon y'a pas le clou et après
le voit effet au mois et lui enlève très
vite et il fait voilà on peut continuer
l'émission donc notre analyse le
meilleur conseil est bien quand tu
mélanges toi même fait une marque au
feutre
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'on est sur une crédibilité
e-magiciens qui fait ça non pour 8 me
disais la vigueur et que la fille elle
fait je me fais chier j'aimerais sortir
[Musique]
c'est son assistant tous ces modes du
public donc je pense me assistant galère
par rapport à son assistant de celui
forcément une assistance
[Musique]
donc là visuellement mais ça ne va pas
très bien puisqu'elle a mis le rideau en
robe
également il ya un balai et gens râler
un peu comme ça s'emballe et apparemment
elle tient comme ça
[Musique]
à oui d'accord ok je vais la mettre
comme ça maintenant
mais qu'elle fuit les combats mais je
pense que c'est un cabaret une série
filmée sans qu'il n'ait pas été alors
qu'en plus tu sais moi ces numéros je
comprends pas pourquoi il existe parce
que même si tu comprends pas le pourquoi
du comment
elle tient tu te dis pas tu dis ça
manque un peu de naturel dans la
fluidité des mouvements tu vois ce que
le dire que tu sens que l'initiation à
la bâthie les pompiers mais c'est sûr et
c'est ce à quoi elle étudie bon je sais
pas pourquoi mais il ya un truc qui
par-delà qui passe par là et qui
rentrent en voiture mais j'ai compris
que mais apparemment qui c'est je crois
que c'est comme un clic clac ils
attendent il a entendu le flic moi ça va
à plat alors ok autant l'aiio est pas
terrible image myriade de pixels autant
là on est soi même concept la catalepsie
sur chaise d'accord qu'on met une
personne d'une planche sur deux chaises
en la personne de sucre mais on enlève
une chaise très bien parce que
bizarrement que jamais enlevé la
deuxième c'est quand même bien sauf lui
alors on récupère les mouvements on s'en
rapporte ans de la mise en scène mais ça
c'est une vraie personne du public par
contre pour ce numéro c'est alors
forcément très à l'aise je la recouvre
d'un drap parce que on est toujours dans
la justification naturel dgs
et puis la transparence
voilà dans une carte mec genre en train
d'imaginer sa chute c'est je sais que
l'embellie chaîne est vraiment tombé
ménard c'était surtout qu'est ce qu'on
aurait pu le sentir que ça allait tomber
oui peut-être pas là la résolution n'est
pas assez bonne pour tu puisses le
mentaliser mais on voit tout sait très
bien qu est ce qu il ya dans sa tête
merde ça ne devrait pas faire ça c'est
ça qui dit il je vais aller au bout trop
tard jeu on est à la télé je vais
forcément aller au bout parce que là je
crois que ça fonctionne
alors tu sais le numéro d' aventure on
remarquera la réaction du public était
la compassion oui oui ribbon larbi que
c'était la réaction du public a été
terrible et instantané
écoutons les applaudissements je
comprends pas je ne
en fait une c ou simplement ils pensent
ils à lesage teinte c'est que j'avais
pas pensé mais je crois que c'est
tromper de chaises en a pas mais je vais
revenir et ouais je pense à l'inversé
les deux chaises la raison il rejoint l
autre nom alors je oui non mais grosso
modo oui je pense qu'il ya sans dévoiler
tous les secrets de ces tours là je
pense qu'il ya une des chaises qui
fonctionnent d'une certaine manière
voilà et qu'à l'installation il l'a
effectivement switch et du coup ça ne
marchait plus avec comme bonne preuve le
fait qu'avant déjà d'enlever sa main ses
pieds touché presque le sol
j'ai une vieille angoisse là qui monte
en moi demierre est-ce que ce mec et
j'ai appris deux chez aspyr inscrire un
numéro à la télévision lui dire tout à
l'heure voilà c'est ça il s'est dit bon
ils ont deux chaises kiplimo si je peux
en chaise pliante
puis un drap ger ger savage viendra du
calcaire du public
on peut le trouver si j'ai la plus rien
ils ont mis ça et moi j'ai vu pas mal de
vidéos faut faire ça ça je lui on le
fait il est le premier surpris ne saviez
pas marché aujourd'hui la télé ça
[Musique]
moi celle ci est fabuleuse j'en connais
aucun depuis très longtemps d'ailleurs
formidable celle ci je veux qu'on l'a
décrite au fur et à mesure nous sommes
je fais des écoles et l'a priori chacun
va présenter un numéro trois au collège
et au lycée je ne sais pas donc il faut
comprendre c'est qu'on récupère toujours
la mécanique d'avoir une boîte sur deux
supports hockey a déjà notable après
tout à fait normal normal il n'y a pas
de hockey n'ont par contre le premier
truc qu'on se dit c'est peut-être dans
l'oreille d'illusions ils se sont gourés
de proportions parce qu'on peut se dire
a priori moi je peux mettre hui personne
dedans oui alors que celle destinée
potentiellement à une personne ok je
joue là j'ai trois éléments
j'ai cédé enfant peut tout à fait et il
ya une si oui oui oui c'est un numéro
raté oui ça fait une vignette a causé la
perte billets donc forcément ça va mal
finir
oui voilà c'est tout pas oui ok donc
voici une boîte complètement normal
nous allons mettre quelqu'un qui a
exactement les dimensions de cette boîte
parce que cette boîte n'est pas trop
grande du tout pour elle c'est vraiment
il ya déjà quinze jours est ce que tu
veux faire d'illusions fonctionne
parfaitement déjà visuellement mélissa
en mai 30 rando stockage on en est ce
que on grandit on est vidé sa 7e jeu là
à tisser là ils regardent jamais de la
surface et pied regardez samba sylvie il
dit même elle devrait sortir ses pieds
que là elle était un peu engoncé ohlala
cette boîte beaucoup trop petit pour moi
à cette lente mais n'ont pas tout de
suite ces malheureuses y remédier
regarde moi je me dis vraiment la taille
du die qu'il lui faudrait dans ta
chambre
c'est incroyable maintenant on va
montrer qu'avec ce coupé en deux ça
fonctionne on ne peut pas lui que bon ça
fonctionne alors quand même laissé
l'écart tout cas cela bien sûr
bon alors parfois il ya des accidents sr
pas fini on s'est dit qu'est ce qui
pourrait se passer d'autres il va tomber
à craquer la table n 3 les trois promus
la table
on termine par une chute babala mais
bien sûr mêmes pilotes
cette sortie la pauvre en graisses et
son humiliation de vie on y voit toute
sa vie avec connards qui vont regarder
ça sur youtube comme tu peux être
d'accord avec moi ce que tu fais de la
scène mais latente du public est très
important dans la vie donc une forte
attente eu peu ça peut être déceptif une
petite à temps mais là c'est une attente
de kermesse donc c'est forcément valable
c'est faible et pourtant tu arrives à
décevoir camp
[Musique]
je la fais un rapide et après je vous
explique comment la fête très bien vous
prenez un jeu vous le mélange est pas du
tout de ce que vous n'êtes pas capable
de mélanger comme je le fais compact
moquer ensuite vous demandez à une
personne lambda
bonsoir je suis très bon menace est ce
que vous pouvez prendre ses cartes et
vous donner les cartes comme ça qu'on
voulait mais vous n'êtes pas obligé
d'égaliser vous parce que tu en es tu
t'arrêtes quand tu veux ne donne pas
toujours fréquentable et là je viens
prendre vraiment ça va être maintenant
ok maintenant tu prends le premier
paquet et tu fais gauche droite gauche
droite comme ça jusqu'à tentures n'est
plus bien que je te fais pareil pour le
deuxième on gagne du temps tu as donné
les cartes comme tu voulais tout arrêter
comme tu voulais et ça nous ferait bien
contents les 4 as sur le dessus et celui
ci vous pouvez leur faire d'accord parce
que c'est exactement la base de 100
tours à quelque chose de mathématiques
qu'on apprend aux enfants habituellement
le secret c'est très humiliant et le
soir ils vont en effet pas dire que
c'est bluffant que c'est pas bleu en
quoi le secret le fonds est le suivant
vous mettez les 4 ha sur le dessus du
jeu oui ok
sous prétexte de lui faire voir vous
commencez à donner quatuor de bien les
dispatcher après il fait ce qu'il veut
on s'en fout et après forcément quand tu
fais un par un ils vont augmenter sur le
dessus c'est possible comme question
mais t'as vu l'émotion que cet apéro
sans dire qui est fait à oui c'est ça je
suis capable de le faire je veux le
faire mais aussi à mes amis récemment
nous avons tourné avec toi à maxime une
vidéo on analysait les gens de la red
box le lien sera dans la vidéo si tenté
que la tienne sorte avant la mienne ce
qui arrivera un petit peu après probable
mais je me fais le lien un petit peu
après tout à fait et vous vous pouvez
vous abonner à la chaîne de maxime en
cliquant ici à la mienne en cliquant là
ici vous avez la vidéo de la semaine
dernière est ici une autre c'est
laquelle ça rentre celle ci voit salah
ouais ouais ouais ben justement c'est la
vidéo de la kermesse exhale la revoir
correct ciao